I'll give one of you 200 bucks if you
punch me in the face
that's fine if you [ __ ] can handle on
Oh congratulations
you [ __ ] la is the best I'm making a
ton of new friends
[Music]
hi I'm Taylor
Ingrid we met before no you do this lot
not anymore
okay you need to realize it's just a
scratch you can buff that right out this
is my brother Nick I yeah what is we go
like these people
Nicky where's my phone jellies favorite
brunch spot is the Fisher for sleeping
those are just a joke
you [ __ ] everybody yet you need a good
start
we all hope you to do right so we're
just gonna scare him a little bit Tupac
said it'd be days like this
[Music]
I'm not a psychopath I just want to be
her friend you've been dating a week and
he's already letting you borrow a truck
I just gave him a [ __ ] damn girl you
move fast
everybody did
oh you're not sure it was an accident
okay anything else I need to know about
ingress he might have done all of your
appropriately thought in it thank you
guys thank you for your service Jimmy
and just gonna say it I gotta let you go
you were just fired how many times by
listen that Logan found the curse than
yours well your brother's missing at all
so more spit this kind of stuff don't
happen to normal folk I have full
custody I'm getting a lawyer with what
money
that's all good some sort of robbery
to-do list Charlotte Motor Speedway
the biggest race in the year I know how
they move the money only God knows about
blowing up bank vault through Joe bang
em in car sure ring and yeah we got a
plan the kitchen round we're gonna do
the full your daughter over bottle we
need like a computer with I know
everything there is no about computers
okay three all the Twitter's I know
you're calm secure location
I'm calling on a phone like a real phone
I'm at the look let's all that's fine
you thought I was gonna use a stick of
dynamite yeah I kinda do a family too
we are dealing with science fear
[Applause]
this has gone down they're gonna know
what we want them to know some are
calling this they feel really tight I
want everything on Jimmy Logan something
you ready I saw what I saw it's a purple
77 Alvarado I'm on my way to church I
don't have time for this step out of the
vehicle ma'am I'm about it naked for no
pay
I said no bacon see you might roll the
clothing first just got you Logan must
be as simple not as painful funny people
say that would you give me my arm please
is it this one
[Music]
Kanaka required frolic years after
Samuel and I lost our daughter we prayed
to feel girl again the contact started
small but she wanted permission to mind
the doll we so realized it wasn't our
daughter so we locked it away we're not
helping the girls could be our pet this
is our new orphanage ah this is a castle
but we're just giving it just wanted
water you know help
you will see that even though we should
be hard we can hail his prison I feel
it's printing prison and even would
clean after me
Bowie you help me or you eat are you ok
fine chain helmet doll
what doll doughnut white dress you
mustn't go to your
[Applause]
Oh Jim walk forgive me sister
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is Michael Bryce how to
I've extracted my client clean up is
required might want to call the bomb
squad
make it the fire department the Mitel
I'm afraid they'll have it be get along
the trial continues one of the world
looks brutal thing right where they keep
witness to testify I can assure you
we're more than that running so
therefore that assault [ __ ]
Kincaid is big you'll be paid the same I
have a job for you the ten foot is in
back what twenty-seven times that's how
many times these [ __ ] tried to kill
me 25 28 you all laugh one hour without
me don't be a little [ __ ] about
Delos where you're hurting me you lost
my car zone that is your job
[Applause]
if you wouldn't mind the gun
you pop dimes
okay country one my bad your bad know
what life gives you [ __ ] you make go
away
life doesn't usually give you [ __ ] and
then turn into a beverage hour is all
that stands between light and darkness
thousands of generations of gunslingers
were Knights sworn to protect it and I'm
the only one left
the tower will fall
get used to the carnage
now the wors comes out
[Music]
do you really think you can stop me
uncie
No
everyone who walks with you dies no more
I cannot shoot with my hands
as you with my mind
do not kill with my gun
I kill over my heart
really something else babe don't you
forget it look at Manship you blame me
look at her I love so much I got a lot
of problems but my relationships one was
a bad girl last night was a night I just
hate thinking about you being with Ken
that's coming up daddy
you are in sweet peace I ask her when
words every damn penny just a sugar
daddy with a any bitty winner of the old
bank account 68 big ones usually ain't
that sweet
I just want to make you happy you know
what make me happy $16,000 I've got a
plan and now it likes nothing now but I
get served
Oh relax take a chill pill okay yeah I'm
Kendra counting on the fourth because I
never asked no God am I gonna hurt you
like hell we are just let a woman
manipulate you as a murder and
kidnapping you got to learn how to stand
up for yourself
can I at least get off my knees hurt
ready to party - well then I won the
best night you like boy put your head in
the game don't even think about it skank
where is mother
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
it isn't not exactly what I call a
healthy relationship chef yeah no
kidding
[Music]
simple alone
[Music]
any emergency assistance the Wind River
Indian Reservation
I'm Dean banner FBI welcome to Wyoming
by yourself it's me that's Cory's
Lambert he's when I found the body
as there's a homicide burnings our girl
she's a fighter
make a big officers to cover an area the
size of Rhode Island maybe you can help
only know its tracks a what is it you do
again auditors so why don't you come
hunt one for me then
why would a teenage ropey out here
what's she running from the other four
clues but you're missing all science
shouldn't we wait for backup this isn't
lend the backup James this is a land of
you're on your own
oh my god
you won't get the answers you're looking
for matter what you find
why your daughter run from home I don't
know why just tell me you you can
happily never be pleased
good it takes Musk it took from you the
key what cousin Cindy betray another
weapon
okay looked on them out here
you
[Music]
hey Victor yeah I'm gonna be everything
I want to be VP olden world has a dream
that dreams are not reality if you
escape with me tonight ah dreams will
come true do you have a plan a brilliant
plan I call them chicken wing chickens
don't fly good morning sunshine
you when's the last time you brush your
teeth will becoming the greatest dancer
and I will become the greatest inventor
ever
I'm the caretaker you can stay with me
and so you get on your feet
starting tomorrow we'll have an audition
to line you ballet she danced I think I
can training starts at 5:00 a.m.
tomorrow 5:00 a.m. just it was stupid to
come to Paris say that we should never
give up on our dreams so how do I get
that part you get the part and passion
is a good performance
[Music]
one day everyone will travel like
[Applause]
[Music]
are you doing nothing I'm stretching I'm
a weapon of Mao's discussion come on
buddy this is gonna be a stealth mission
don't tell me you're scared
there's nothing safer than a dark alley
ah just a lovable little dolly okay
that's a little creepy dang this is bad
it's been nice knowing you buddy
you scared us a cute little guy Oh some
call me killed
Oh got it my name is mr. Fang I was
cursed with this big adorable eyes and
this fuzzy little body why are you here
I need your help to take back the park
this Park has everything we need the
mayor wants to destroy everything I got
bigger plants and trees an amusement
park they're going to destroy the park
that's not good don't you see we're all
animals we need to look out for each
other
we are ended together if you want to
stop the merit is going it squirrel sees
it's going to pick everyone when should
we do try to not get killed I'll try but
it can't make any promises
individually we might be tiny but
together with giant you doing roll over
I don't know how I'm not classically
trained don't get it boys
I'm the weapon of mouth disgusted drink
ass little rodents if they stop me
wow this is gonna be fun
now
[Music]
meet my new friend mr. Fang that reminds
me
don't call him shoot
[Music]
I say I gotta come clean with you about
what so I told you about my brother yeah
I told you about the program is forced
to attend a now you shouldn't be there
don't count your chickens before they
catch you understand that
nope something happened I'll know
exactly what bugs been arrested being
held at Rikers Island we get killed in
there all right you just have a client
that walked in again you get another ten
grand
the boat will get out where are you how
much money can you get right now roll oh
my gosh you kidding me you think I'm
doing this for you I want to be not
blood
[Music]
[Music]
don't be confused just going to make the
worse to me every time before okay I
want you commitment you are going on
love it
this place where we are now and be a lot
of fun if you ever
and then have a good time
[Music]
you
that's me though Angie came home at 5 in
the morning
[Music]
and the boardwalk another five so how'd
it go with that girl you want to take a
walk on the beach you ever made out with
a girl before sure lots of times she's
hot when few girls made out can you
comment two guys make out I don't really
know yes I don't know just let me be let
me ask her or something
I just feel about getting highly getting
up you have to do this much name take a
little fart
I probably have 250 plus typewriters in
my collection and I would say that 90%
of them are in perfect working his eye
brighter doesn't judge you just right
away sir
right away sir however you want to be
there's a tactful satisfaction that's I
think part of our humanity individually
as degree our culture but the big
picture of the coast rebuilding again
since herbs got a dream that people are
going to come back to Tartarus I think
you think somewhat of a wave of the
future
who's willing to spend as last time when
I take the typewriters apart I see
people at the Ottomans I was having this
rebellious moment this feeling of things
sick of a digital world how intrusive it
is I went to my typewriter and wrote
down a manifesto you assert our right to
resist paradigm to rebel against the
information regime to escape the data
stream we strike a blow for
self-reliance privacy and coherence this
is our first type end display having
been bumping like this in a while we
affirm the written word and written
thought against multimedia multitasking
and the mean which is the real of a
representation the physical over the
digital the self-sufficient over the
efficient the revolution will be
typewritten
we say folk in fancy apartments with
their hair so polluted they can see
stars would that be out of our minds
trade places with any other dr. Kaler
said was you know a real school a real
school this is as real as it gets kids
you learn from lemming hack yourself a
new person back yourself flavoring I'm
gonna come should be change of us just
as we choose a different life calling
you if you lose your sense the future if
the song don't go getting measure on
tape that's one can be bad you can't be
tired of moving to a new town every time
you lose a job your oldest running runs
only temporary we just need perfect
location then we can get to work on our
castle
this place doesn't have any running
water or electricity ignore her she was
born without Beijing my parents are
squatting an abandoned building on the
Lower East Side you honestly tell me
that you happy right yes I am water me
like the people got a fire burn Alex you
were born to change the world not just
add to the noise why do you think all of
us ran away from you we were drowning I
can't let you cling to the side your
whole life just go your skin give it
your job to protect us you have a right
to be angry no you love him
you ready
[Music]
ow
you may take me my compressor in 1634
Amsterdam was captivated by a flower
rich and poor gambled on the tulip
market they feel with the beautiful
orphan chosen by one of the richest men
in the city the bay I've decided to
engage the services of a painter don't
move put your brush to capturing my wife
she's a rare beauty they'll say at that
lucky or dark didn't he have a lovely
young wife to flower
[Music]
shooter business I think it's the offer
to my problem if I were rich I could
take you away he would find her he will
not come for me honest with my lord I
pray that my wife shall be not of
corruptible seed you've been busy
you're not in painting no offense I made
a plan to do with but we will
nothing that risk
but a lot I bought Sofia
[Music]
don't
you two really think your kindness off
[Music]
you
you boys done playing there's a song for
training for the Olympic training for
the street
action
Master
come on Jack men you leave in the
Shaolin Temple
check out come through in America people
in Chinatown don't like that I teach
white Shaolin said Wong Jack man is
Bayan he may be the only person in this
world who can tear down everything I've
been working so hard to build up sooner
or later
gonna have to fight him what does see
fully teaching it teaches us to kick ass
she can their technique is impressive
but it has one limitation right Q I'm
the future you're the path to your
relevant wall fightin I accept your
challenge
waived up for their hands never doubted
man a new thing but it makes little
place
no rules no holes no limit you guys kill
each other
now it began to reach easier limit one
minute
never show you my one-inch punch Tony
you